es gab kritik auch aus den reihen derer
für die jetzt rolf mützenich spricht
nämlich der vorsitzende der spd fraktion
allerdings an einzelnen punkten der
bundesregierung mal schauen wie viele
davon jetzt wiederholt und kollegen ich
möchte gerne mit zwei momentaufnahmen
aus meiner heimatstadt beginnen
dort setzt ein fotograf menschen ins
bild die positives in dieser pandemie
erlebt haben seit zwölf monaten
begleitet er diese menschen und mit der
haltung mut machen und hoffnung gehen
und dort sagt zum beispiel der direktor
der kölner feuerwehr wie menschen
zusammen die last der krise stemmen
wollen
das ist phänomenal das ist was ich finde
was wir mit respekt gegenüber vielen
menschen hier in deutschland sagen
müssen recht haben die eben sagen wir
wollen uns auch ganz persönlich gegen
diese pandemie stimmung ist
beeindruckend wie viele menschen
außerordentliches geleistet haben und
auch auf sie kommt es in den nächsten
wochen anderen deswegen sage ich meine
damen und herren zuversicht geben ist
neben dem impfen die beste medizin und
genau das hat unser land verdient
und zum zweiten zusammen mit dem
fraunhofer institut hat die stadt köln
am montag eine untersuchung vorgelegt
über das infektionsgeschehen im
vergangenen jahr waren es die linke auf
der linksrheinischen kölner seite die
stadtteile gewesen die etwas besser
situiert sind und die dortigen die das
untersucht haben haben gesagt das waren
die ischgl heimkehrer heute ist die
pandemie in den ärmeren stadtteilen im
rechtsrheinischen köln
und doch hat die pandemie die sozialen
verwerfungen noch weiter vertieft
deswegen sage ich die zweite antwort auf
diese pandemie ist ein starker
sozialstaat und wir können
das in den nächsten jahren stemmen und
gerade wir sozialdemokratinnen und
sozialdemokraten werden das tun dass
soziale muss in dieser pandemie genauso
im mittelpunkt stehen wie die
medizinischen herausforderung und
deswegen denke ich auch dass gestern das
bundeskabinett den erleichterten zugang
zur kurzarbeit um weitere drei monate
verlängert hat und ich würde mich auch
freuen wenn das betriebsräte stärkung
gesetz noch den deutschen bundestag
erreicht auf den ersten blick hat das
vielleicht nichts mit der pandemie zu
tun
aber beim zweiten blick wissen wir dass
genau die unternehmen wo mitbestimmung
herrscht genau sich dieser pandemie am
besten entgegenstemmen wo die
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer gut
aufgehoben sind da unterstützen sie auch
das unternehmen und da kann es auch
gemeinsam gelingen gegen die pandemie zu
arbeiten und liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen jeder beschluss zur eindämmung
desinfektions geschehens ist nicht ohne
risiko und auch nicht ohne widerspruch
ich hoffe das behauptet hier niemand
dass ein einziger oder eine einzige
genau weiß was das richtige ist aber der
unterschied ist doch zu anderen ländern
auf der welt und das ist das
anstrengende ja in einer demokratie und
insbesondere in einem rechtsstaat muss
man unterschiedliche güter auch abwägen
und genau das ist auch was wir in diesem
jahr der bekämpfung der pandemie getan
haben aber die einzige aussicht auf die
wertung der pandemie und das haben sie
gesagt frau bundeskanzlerin ist das
impfen ja es gab zu viele
nachlässigkeiten in den letzten monaten
aber es kommt jetzt darauf an und da
zähle ich auch auf das wort was sie für
das gesamte kabinett gegeben haben dass
alle verantwortlichen in diesen tagen
dafür arbeiten müssen dass es in den
nächsten wochen reibungsloser läuft und
wenn es stimmt und es stimmt dass die
brücke durch das testen auch gebildet
werden kann
dann hätte ich mir aber das kann ich nur
persönlich sagen mehr mut möglicherweise
auch von den ministerpräsidentinnen
ministerpräsidenten
aber auch von ihnen frau bundeskanzlerin
gewünscht nicht erst am 14 april in
einer verordnung das testen in den
unternehmen zu verlangen sondern das
hätte man auch jetzt tun können weil
wenn es stimmt dass die pandemie dass
das infektionsgeschehen auch gerade in
den unternehmen so stark weiter gegeben
wird hätte man dies jetzt auch
verbindlich tun können aber ich sage
dies auch mit deutlichkeit und mit
großem respekt sie haben einen fehler
eingeräumt
für andere die verantwortung dort
mittragen und ich finde das umso
respektabler bei einige kunden das
kündigen das zwar an aber entschuldigen
sich nicht und ich finde das macht den
unterschied auch aus wir haben viel
haben uns besser besserwisserei in
unserem land erlebt auch immer wieder
hier in diesem parlament manchmal
überrascht mich dass wir alles zum
experten als epidemiologe mutiert ist in
diesem saal oder bestimmte studien auch
vorhält aber ich finde das entscheidende
ist
rechthaberei darf in diesem haus nicht
um sich greifen und deswegen kann ich
nur auch an die oppositionsparteien
sagen ich wäre vorsichtig an deren
stelle weil wenn man vor vier jahren von
der verantwortung weggelaufen ist sollte
man viel bescheidener an diesen stellen
auftreten was man mit rechthaberei eben
nicht erreichen kann und gleichzeitig
will ich auch daran erinnern dass
mindestens zwei oppositionsparteien zwei
ministerpräsidenten in die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz entsenden
und ich gehe ja zum beispiel mal davon
aus dass ministerpräsident laschet mit
dem stellvertretenden
ministerpräsidenten der fdp sich auch
abstimmt also von daher würde ich schon
sagen der finger der immer wieder auf
die anderen zeigt zeigt auch auf sich
selbst wieder zurück meine damen und
herren ein bisschen zurückhaltung ein
bisschen mehr respekt vor dem handeln
insbesondere auch derjenigen nicht nur
die im bund sondern im land aber eben
auch in den kommunen verantwortung
tragen hätte ich mir auch von
gewünscht meine damen und herren die
pandemie wird uns noch lange begleiten
deswegen ist neben dem impfen neben dem
impfen die finanzielle verantwortung die
dieses land die dieser staat die diese
bundesrepublik deutschland gegen die
pandemie entgegen stemmen kann und
deswegen will ich sagen ich bin dankbar
dass das bundeskabinett gestern dem
bundeshaushalt den bundeshaushalt
entwurf für das jahr 2022 auf den weg
gebracht hat und die mittelfristige
finanzplanung und deswegen will ich auch
an den koalitionspartner sagen das ist
die entscheidung des gesamten kabinetts
und das ist auch die entscheidung der
koalition und nicht des finanzministers
und ich finde so müssen wir auch in den
nächsten wochen über diese großen
finanziellen lasten die wir auf uns
nehmen wollen sprechen es ist eine
verantwortung des ganzen landes und wir
müssen mit aller finanziellen kraft uns
auch der pandemie entgegenstellen
deswegen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
von der union und liebe frau
bundeskanzlerin an dogmen festhalten
bringt in dieser krise nichts und
deswegen habe ich mich gefreut als
damals der kanzleramtsminister ich habe
bescheiden gedachte sei auch in ihrem
einvernahmen mit ihrem einvernehmen
gewesen offenheit über die
schuldenbremse signalisiert hat und dass
gerade ministerpräsident laschet diesem
versuch zumindestens dogmen zu
überwinden direkt wieder aufgehoben hat
hat mich dann doch schon überrascht wir
sagen in 20 jahren wollen wir die
schulden getilgt haben
in dem bundesland das zusammen mit der
fdp regiert wird sollen es 50 jahre sein
das ist doch wohl ein großer unterschied
wie man verantwortung auf sich nimmt und
wie man sozusagen aus einer
oppositionsrolle auf der einen seite und
auf der anderen seite mit
regierungsverantwortung handeln kann ich
finde das nicht seriös deswegen danke
ich sehr dass das bundeskabinett gestern
beschlossen hat und zum schluss ja frau
bundeskanzlerin europa ist unsere
lebensversicherung im kampf gegen die
pandemie aber insbesondere auch vor dem
hintergrund der wirtschaftlichen
erholung und deswegen versprechen
von ihren gesprächen eben das bei dem
impfen dieser zusammenhalt gestärkt wird
aber insbesondere auch über fehler
nachgedacht wird und es ist eine große
chance glaube ich auch in dieser
situation dass sie auch heute abend mit
dem amerikanischen präsidenten darüber
sprechen werden weil es ist etwas ganz
neues dass wir zumindest in washington
nicht mehr europa zwischen alt und neu
eingeteilt wird sondern dass europa von
seiten der usa von seiten der us
regierung eine chance bekommt am
abschluss will ich sagen ja sie haben
die türkei kritisiert dass sie aus der
istanbul konvention ausgetreten ist ich
finde
von diesem rat muss aber ein noch
wichtigeres zeichen ausgehen dass
nämlich andere länder wie zum beispiel
polen wo die polnische regierung sagt
auch wir werden die istanbul konvention
möglicherweise verlassen oder kroatien
oder eben ungarn von diesem rat muss ein
klares zeichen ausgehen ein wir stehen
eben zu dieser istanbul konvention wir
wollen uns dafür einsetzen
und wenn das eins der ergebnisse neben
der bekämpfung der pandemie und der
wirtschaftlichen erholung in europa ist
wird das eine gute konferenz vielen dank
[Applaus]